delphine est ce que tu as senti voulait
taper chaud non mais non sarah du tout
parce qu'en plus moi j'en vois beaucoup
de coeur rouge par exemple ils sont
hyper c'est toi bien voir reçoit un
coeur rouge tu vas te dire tout de suite
et
reçoit que rouge il appelle la synagogue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le président déambuler dans les allées
de rucks d'eurexpo s'appelle comme ça le
chef de l'état était visible par un g
dof
[Musique]
on peut ne pas être d'accord avec le
président on peut être pas être d'accord
avec plein de choses mais là c'est un
manque de respect ami qui voulait juste
faire une omelette regarde
vous voyez un g2 tout de suite
interpellation pas facile
c'est facile moi je vais vous dire
j'avais interpellé le gie fleurs de
macron là je me suis fait des boîtes et
là pendant trois quatre jours sur les
réseaux sociaux alors je leur dis les
menaces de mort ça vous pouvez continuer
je m'en bats les reins total et je suis
juif maintenant sur ce sale juive de
témoin
le souci c'est que ça veut dire que l'on
veut on cherche même plus à dialoguer ou
même appelé en disant je ne suis pas
d'accord avec vous et c'est là ce qu'on
veut c'est simplement faire un film avec
la ennuyant et en usant qu'ils ont et en
respectant pas la fonction
le polémiste et probable candidat à la
présidentielle bon il va se présenter ou
pas tous et nous
on espère ouais ça je pense qu'il va y
aller oui moi je penses tu vas y avait
on alors il va y aller on a vu où on
vous a fait le week end eric zemmour
regardez franchement ça annule l art là
franchement très sincère c'est un
candidat tu vas voter pour lui doit un
nom pour benoît hamon
m
chez lui c'est la première fois que tu
vas voter non plus ah ouais exactement 7
par dix ce qui me plaît chez lui c'est
son diagnostic s'est il a une façon de
parler extrêmement claire et son départ
attend notamment à l'identité la
sécurité d'ailleurs je pense que ce qui
s'est passé aujourd'hui prouve encore
par l'exemple ce qui décrit en fait à
longueur de temps cercle en france
aujourd'hui on peut se faire cracher
dessus on peut se rassurer la rue et
l'insécurité moi si j'ai par exemple je
m'engage justement c'est parce que je
pense à l'avenir le pays moi je respecte
beaucoup et en espagne avec zemmour à
moi je pense qu'on peut faire quelque
chose
il part très vite
mais redescend très vite
[Musique]
un rêve de jeunesse que je dis mais
c'est quoi sa mévente voudraient avancer
en temps je peux répondre qui me parlait
de sa région ps seraient tous ici et je
fais quoi le plus jeune tu comprends pas
que avant
montré qu'ils étaient morts
j
[Musique]
mais comprend pas ça
télé pendant que j'avais
c'est donc avec moi
oui
m
[Musique]
je savais qu'il était un peu sanguin
après écoute et il a fait un choix il a
fait choix la drôle adore moi j'adore il
a fait choix là c'est vrai pendant le
pendant que vinyle avait plu voilà il y
avait plus de deux d'école extérieur il
a eu envie de ça l'expérience il est
heureux et le relais je crois qu'il est
très heavy s'améliore bien abattre l
archipel arriver sa mère mais
franchement génial on est très content
avec sa meuf la l'adduction apparemment
se passe très bien oui c'est qu'il est
avec ses listes alex de ne pas gober
que midi l'homme qui a été condamné
l'année dernière pour agresser le
polémiste est avec nous on se rappelle
tous il s'était vanté sur les réseaux
sociaux d'avoir craché sur eric zemmour
il sera en plateau dans un instant avec
nous regarder d'abord ces images qui
avaient énormément choqué l on dit
choqué stan
ouais c'est que les semaines précédentes
vous a fait plaisir alors mehdi est avec
nous ben merci d'être là mais dit mehdi
est ce que déjà tu regrettes ton juste
regretter mon geste
est un grand mot t'aurais pas aimer
plutôt allé le voir lui parler lui dire
je suis pas du tout d'accord avec toi
pour ça pour ça est ce que tu dis voilà
sur l'islam ça je suis pas d'accord avec
toi il essayait d'exposer des arguments
en face de lui mais le problème c'est
que en fait c'est quand j'ai fait ce
geste quand j'allais agressé moi je
regrette pas d'accord je reste sur mes
propos je le regrette pas ce que j'ai
fait
cliquez sûr que tu allais de faire
cramer derrière bas je pensais pas
j'avais un petit peu de monde sur snap
la vidéo elle a commencé à tourner et
c'est parti sur twitter top tweets et
après ça et ça pouvait plus s'arrêter
mais mettons jetons geste il est
franchement je te lis il est
inadmissible je te le dis mais dit c'est
que dans cette vidéo il dit c'est
impossible de parler avec lui il est
super fort n'a pas insulté sa mère vous
voulez faire quoi on va dire on
reconnaît qu'ils vont y reconnaissent à
la spirit et des mureaux des ballons ce
qui est quand même dommage en plus
spécialisés mort à quelqu'un qui accepte
le débat d'idées dont qui aurait pu
tenter de le faire de rade après il fait
une vidéo le soir là à mon avis pour son
avocat ou pour des raisons juridiques en
expliquant que vous regrettiez le vous
n'auriez jamais dû faire ça un peu une
vidéo de pleureuses où vous dit non non
c'est l'histoire c'était plusieurs jours
pauliste est toujours produit jours plus
tard la voilà vous avez été d'ailleurs
je crois condamné pour ça c'est bien
normal en tant que co vide en plus trash
et sur quelqu'un je pressens que ça va
venir cracher dessus après je vous ai
menti sur sa alors qu'on faisait monter
sur ça c'était dans le feu de l'action
ah d'accord avec moi quand je croise si
froid jean luc mélenchon d'art où il
faut je les suive si dans le feu de
l'action le fait une vidéo instagram
oserais je vais cracher dessus
des chars qui sont aux normes et j'ai ma
mère j'ai l'ex femme de mon mari est bon
des charges qui à en croire véronique
jeunesse pour atteindre presque dix
mille euros certains moi s'il vous faut
qu'on bat pour vivre beaucoup d'huile
par mois ouais bah oui facile assez
compliqué à la elle a eu sa vie où elle
faisait des julie lescaut à 130 milles
140 milles l'épisode si je dis pas de
conneries donc forcément pour être dix
mille euros mais quand elle parle a
annoncé 120000 euros faut dix ans pour
gagner 120 millions et elle a dit quand
on y arrive pas avec 10000 euros mais si
ce procès d'intention s'est
déjà payé un minimum
quel montant il ya quelques moments dans
celle des enfants qui se met tous
ensemble moi dans mon dedans - bruce et
les enfants qui se met tous ensemble
meriem alliance pour payer leurs moments
parce qu'on la sort examen de leur mère
ou après s'il vous faut dix mille euros
par mois tant mieux pour être sûr il
faut dix mille euros problème parce
qu'il faut expliquer aussi c'est que
c'est des trains de vie particulier ça
vous enfermer dans un mode de vie c'est
un métier on peut tout perdre du jour au
lendemain il ya énormément de gens
autour de vous qui dépendent de vous que
vous payez il ya énormément de gens qui
se font inviter tout le temps je pense
que benjamin a vécu une payer bruit
plein de gens ferment quand vous allez
au restaurant c'est toujours pour vous
pendant dix ans j'ai cas voilà un guide
de restaurants ben ouais c'est jamais on
part on va avec castagnetta sont hilares
ainsi des chemins non parce que je
déteste et des potes mais c'est comme si
en plus c'est normal dont vous êtes le
restaurant et j'ai des copains qui n'est
pas d'argent il faut leur dire de payer
l'addition exactement la main de chaînes
qu'elle est l'addition la plus folle
comme des rivières s'est testé à la
céleste vegas d'accord ce que j'avais
invité l'adresse d'un mois dans une
renault et il y avait en baisse de 25
personnes en région comptait près de la
carte ils choisissent le vin et là vous
commencez à translab
à las vegas à des vins c'est mon frère
six mois d'avancé des maisons qua non
non et je vois cheval blanc quinze mille
dollars jeudi en panneaux celui-là
passants mais n'ont pas non plus voté
non
ça crée une balle dollar vers l'est mais
l'officier
la plus grosse folie en restant un autre
fou à l'hôtel l'avion mais quand vous
avez fait un truc que vous avez fait le
fou d'elle ça peut monter ou un
débat
regardons ça faisait ça monte vite à des
prix tout le formule 1 pour vous ouais
voilà sous l'effet des prix tous les
tâches d'un hôtel de manhattan on voit
ça coûte et je pense très cher arrêté
après c'est fini on sait très bien que
c'est il ya 50 ans voilà donc c'est peut
être je sais pas cinquante cinq mille
dollars la nuit un débit pas dormir la
même manière chez moi je te mets à
colombo
[Applaudissements]
j'ai envie de faire exceptionnellement
ce soir
qui balance qui
chacun va balancer un dos sur une
personne son spectacle j'ai prêté une de
mes voitures à benjamin week end une
nourriture de sport ça commence par l
jeudi par hbo voilà nîmes a dit est-ce
que je peux t'emprunter ta voiture pour
aller en week-end et une boccolini
beaucoup dit
tu prends la voiture il m'envoie une
photo fièrement sur l'autoroute en train
de rouler très très vite non non et 15
minutes plus tard il m'appelle la
voiture défoncée
n'ont ils pas bon et pour vous prouver
que ça dure que c'est vrai pour vous
prouver que c'est un ignoble le mytho
dans l'émission il était venu avec des
avec des bandelettes xinjian me suis
fait je me suis fait mal avec mon grip
un choc violent
à
combien non je n'ai pas la preuve que je
n'allais pas être jeune et je n'ai rien
eu du tout j'ai même pas été baissé rien
à la volée on s'en souvient à malhao
john est mort chez lui à choisir entre
vous et la voiture il a choisi la
voiture est en fait et en fait j'ai
mordu un petit peu sur la neige et là je
suis parti en tête à queue non ah oui et
j'ai fait un coup à droite un coup à
gauche un coup à droite un coup à gauche
une voiture
j'ai tapé et l'avant et derrière et le
côté droit
moi je n'ai pas de dossier c'est
peut-être une confession mais pas de
dossier une confession intime
moi j'ai chiné delphine sur instagram
attendez attendez c'est déjà envoyé les
chevaux j'ai tout ouvrir tout comme
benjamin tête l'accueil est honnête
envoyer des joutes bas on voit des joues
pas des voitures
[Applaudissements]
durant sa garde qui ont besoin de fait
sens quant à ya d'autres choses à faire
au moins trois quatre mois quand un de
ses plus
beaux parce que c'est fort à le dire
déjà assez fort d'y croire mais
c'était quand
est-ce que tu as senti voulait taper
chaud à non mais non sarah dit tout
parce qu'en plus moi j'en vois beaucoup
de coeur rouge par exemple ils sont
hyper c'est toi bien moindre soin coeur
rouge tu vas te dire tout de suite
il reçoit que le rouge il appelle la
synagogue
on voit pas de cachet que les arabes et
cela alors mais tu l'envoies hackers
service ne lui envoie jamais d'abricots
[Musique]
toujours pas payer la dette qui n'ont
même pas mis d'échéancier en place qui
ne travaillent pas et lola manon jala
quand sonne
c'est vous qui le dites et moi c'est
vous et moi j'ai des noms vous mes
copains
pouvez écouter l'audio si c'était
possible dure quarante secondes oui
c'est mathieu la mer qui laisse un
message vocal à ma copine parce qu'elle
n'a pas reçu le règlement et qui
explique que ce que le petit va manger
[Applaudissements]
c'est moi qui non c'est moi qui le dit
c'est moi qui mets vous savez ce que ça
vous savez ce que c'est mais vous savez
c'est le minimum
il a quatre ans il n'a pas dit s'il
avait mangé
[Musique]
genton a dit je me laisse jusqu'à
décembre pour kate delphine 1 sinon je
me rabattrai sursaut ticos
[Applaudissements]
mentalement
je me laisse jusqu'à novembre
ses fils m'a invité à dîner non ouais
ouais ouais ben là c'est au costes
et tu penses que tu as une chance avec
est sophie koch celle ci m'a proposé
il m'a dit les choix à beauvois la
libreta voiture sp la lituanie j'ai eu
très chaud non c'est ouais non c'est
vrai elle a dit je vais te fais tout ton
oreille
non parce que là je vais te dire un truc
d'où
un chroniqueur envoyé par erreur une
photo de moi nue
à une personne de la prod initiales sont
baissées non je pense que c'est là la
personne ait envoyé une vidéo nu de la
personne lui oui je pense et s'avéra
castany c'est quoi cette fois non non
non non non non non
[Applaudissements]
et écoutons alors qu il sera au salon du
téton de leurs mots refuse de participer
à une émission présentée par castaldi ou
bernard montiel non
si des bombes et non c'est faux c'est
vrai c'était faux c'est vrai j'aimerais
c'est faux
ça me paraît c'est bizarre non
ça me paraissait bizarre des dettes non
mais je me suis dit bon thé animateurs
tu passes chroniqueur après si tu
deviens chroniqueur de chroniqueurs
ouahbi chroniqueur du chroniqueur de
chroniqueurs rien abandonner la descente
aux enfers
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]